the aftermath of a string of recent
bombings and arson attacks in foja a
small city in southern italy
no injuries were reported but the
message was clear the local mafia was
pushing back
over the past two years police have
seized millions of dollars in assets and
made several arrests
some businesses are now refusing to pay
protection money to the mafia
alessandro zito ran a construction firm
here until his business was burned down
by the mob facing death threats he
relocated his family he now heads the
newly launched local anti-racketing
association
by some estimates 70 of businesses here
pay protection to the mafia a figure we
can't confirm
with the association we are trying to
show people they are not alone the only
way to root out this problem is to stand
up together
in the wake of the bombings police have
increased patrols and investigations and
set up roving checkpoints poor and
underdeveloped like much of the south
florida has been the base for the
so-called fourth mafia for decades
unknown to many outside italy the
collection of clans in the area make
most of their money off extortion drug
trafficking and prostitution
the bombings weren't just directed at
people not paying protection the owner
of this flower shop that was bombed
wouldn't speak to us on camera but she
said no one ever came here asking her
for money and that's what scares her
most investigators say these attacks
were meant to spread fear
prosecutor antonio laronga showed us the
mafia's reach here and how they control
this area on the southeast coast of
italy the organization the organization
clearly feels the need for marketing
these attacks are meant to send a clear
message
we are here
despite recent gains laronga isn't
convinced they'll take the local mafia
down soon
i'm not optimistic the path to justice
is going to be a long one there are some
hopeful signs but the situation is still
uncertain there are lots of powerful
clans and a culture of crime here
luca vigilante and his family run a
chain of health clinics in the area
treating thousands of patients
the mafia came calling despite the risks
his family said no
in the future if my children follow in
my footsteps in this work
after teaching them their whole life
about morality ethics christian values
i'd have to say look if you want to
continue this work you'll have to give
money to criminals it would be
hypocritical and absurd a really awful
thing for them
not all here feel they can stand up to
the mob they know when the police aren't
there to protect them the mafia could
come calling again adam rainey al
jazeera folje italy